[Musique]
il ya tellement déchets partout les gens
et en met partout
il a récolté 110 tonnes d'objets acheter
c'est voter je consommateurs quand il
vient ici c'est aussi pour faire un
geste éco-responsable j'aimerais bien 0
kg actuellement je sais qu'il y en a qui
arrivent quasiment zéro kg après c'est
un petit peu d exemple voilà difficile à
suivre
magalie 38 ans rentre du supermarché
faire ses courses là-bas n'est pas
évident pour elle cet adepte du zéro
déchet à acheter du quinoa des légumes
des pâtes
le tout sans emballage c'est un petit
peu compliqué parce qu'on voit tout une
marraine de plastique et donc c'est
vraiment un travail aussi sur soi au
début de dire un non il ne faut pas tout
acheter il faut vraiment choisir ce dont
on a réellement besoin mais il ya quand
même des choses comme le vinaigre que je
suis obligé d'acheter qui est quand même
en grande surface en packagée
effectivement magali a commencé à
réduire ses déchets il y a deux ans si
son frigo abrite encore des produits
emballés
elle sent la différence j'ai quand même
beaucoup diminué puisqu'on est passé là
actuellement j'étais à 380 kg par an et
je suis passé à 40 kg sa poubelle se
réduit maintenant à un tiroir qu'on a de
l'aluminium on à du métal
on a la boîte à compost qui va finir
dans le composteur mais que ce soit pour
le compostage le refus des emballages ou
les produits à faire soi même
magali a besoin de conseils pour changer
ses habitudes
alors tu viens de présenter des
nouveautés oui mathilde est une
couturière spécialisé dans les
accessoires zéro déchet je sais pas si
tu les avais vus oui d'accord oui non
j'ai sélectionné donc tu t'en sers tu
leur as tu le laisse sécher et tu dors
sert en fait chaque jour où taclant
toujours comme tu veux plus que vendre
elle veut surtout partager ses astuces
elle montre ainsi à magali comment
fabriquer une éponge avec des restes de
vêtements
et hop tu as fait ton éponge et voilà on
peut pas devenir zéro déchet du jour au
lendemain c'est petit à petit c'est à
son niveau à son échelle comme on veut
c'est ce qu'on voit là tout dépend ce
qu'on ressent il y en a qui vont
commencer par la lessive
alors que moi je trouve ça compliqué de
faire des lessives mathilde est
d'ailleurs intrigué par les produits de
magali dont son dentifrice tu fais
comment je sais qu'on voit beaucoup de
recettes effectivement moi j'ai choisi
celle où il y avait du bicarbonate de
soude encore une fois du sel j'ai acheté
une base on va dire de quelques produits
qui me servent à plein de choses et avec
ça j'arrive à faire beaucoup de produits
qu'on voit ici
au delà des économies jusqu'à 1400 euros
par an pour les plus engagés magali et
mathilde se sentent surtout bien dans
leur peau mais plus en phase avec
moi-même par rapport aux problèmes
environnementaux parce qu'on nous dit
tout le temps il faut faire il faut
faire il faut faire mais concrètement
comment on fait les choses et donc la
main petit pas par petit passe et chaque
petit éléments contribuent en fait à
faire un quelque chose pour
l'environnement faire quelque chose pour
l'environnement
c'est ce qui a poussé arnaud et
gwendoline à passer au vrac en zone
rurale je reviens du d'une grande
surface quelle qu'elle soit d'un
commerce qu'elle perçoit j'ai un tas
d'emballages par rapport à ce qu'il ya
dans l'emballage
je n'étais jamais aperçu un des
principes du zéro déchet on le disait
c'est de refuser les emballages en
allant acheter en vrac
sept mois après l'ouverture de leur
épicerie arnaud et gwendoline ont déjà
un aperçu de leur impact
plus de 22000 coton tige mille
bouteilles de gel douche ou encore 5800
paquet plastifiée n'ont pas été jetée
grâce aux 900 produits référencés ici un
chiffre en hausse car le couple convainc
de plus en plus de producteurs de livré
en vrac
arnaud accueille un des derniers arrivés
qui fournit des spiritueux et viennent
avec leurs contenants bas comme ils sont
surpris de découvrir là ils ont pas ils
sont pas équipés donc les producteurs
qui créent leurs produits de la même
manière sauf qu'au lieu de mettre en
bouteille voilà finalement ils ont mis
leurs produits respectifs demandé dans
des fûts ou dans des dans des bidons que
arnaud a récupéré puis c'est pas plus
compliqué pour nous c'est des
contraintes qu'aux nouveaux étiquetages
parce qu'il faut prévoir un étiquetage
temps réglementaire avec les nouveaux
qui vont bien les les termes obligatoire
comme sur n'importe quelle bouteille
c'est beaucoup plus de travailler en
amont que simplement mettre la bouteille
dans un rêve arnaud ne se fait pas
seulement livrés en vrac
ils échangent un bidon de vodka
consignés contre un autre vide
et quand les bidons ne sont pas consigné
l'épicier les stocks dans la cave pour
les réutiliser ou les donner en cette
morne acheté aucun bilan c'est un bilan
de 25 litres on a dû en donner à peu
près une centaine le disais c'est pas de
que les gens aient moins de poubelles
pour que nous on en est deux fois plus
voilà ça reviendra servir à rien ça n'a
pas de sens le décideront de recirculer
du recyclé de ré utiliser au maximum les
décomptes ans
[Musique]
la question de diminuer ces déchets
préoccupe aussi certaines entreprises
industrielles notamment quand il s'agit
de faire des économies
[Musique]
à amboise
mecachrome fabrique et assemble des
armatures d'avions pour airbus ou
bombardier mais pour usiner ces pièces
en aluminium ou en titane
il faut du lubrifiant beaucoup de
lubrifiants 150 mètres cubes sont
injectés par mois c'est autant que la
consommation annuelle en haut d'un foyer
de quatre personnes
il a été mis en place en groupe mais
quatre différentes technologies pour
réduire ces lubrifiants maintenant on ne
peut pas réduire sur l'ensemble des
parcs machine tout simplement parce que
le lubrifiant
il a avant tout là pour l'usst
inhabilité des pièces mais aussi chasser
des propos qui sont générés
si les métaux sont vendus pour être
réutilisés recyclés le lubrifiant un
produit polluant et plus complexe
pourtant depuis 2012 l'entreprise leur
retraite en interne
le lubrifiant et inspiré dans cet
appareil via une pompe
ça nous permet de traiter de régénérer
de daisy les filtrer pour obtenir une
qualité du brief y en a près un analyste
qui permet d'être réinjectée dans le
circuit de production des différentes
visites
c'est une volonté clairement de
l'entreprise pour diminuer ces déchets
le lubrifiant nettoyer est ici analysé
il peut être de mauvaise qualité et
écarter ou conformes aux normes est
réinjecté donc là tu es bon ok je vous
fais la fondation hockey
ce processus a permis à mika chrome
d'acheter deux fois moins de lubrifiants
et d'économiser 130 mille euros par an
mais le recyclage ne s'arrête pas là une
fois que les contenants en fait sont
vidés de produits on les nettoie et on
passe par des filières de traitement
pour remettre dans les circuits
ces contenants après
si les entreprises ont les moyens de
recycler les déchets encombrants
les particuliers eux ont parfois la
solution des ressourceries qui redonne
vie aux objets cassés ou l'usagé la
ressourcerie d'orléans en a collecté 110
tonnes l'an dernier dont la quasi
totalité a été valorisé une association
qui va aussi à la rencontre des
habitants dans les quartiers
prioritaires
[Musique]
le temps d'un après midi
pauline son équipe installe dans le
quartier des blossières au nord
d'orléans
un atelier mobile pour relooker du
mobilier ici des poubelles de poubelles
normaux cela pourrait peut-être aller
belle peut-être aller moche si jamais
vous avez envie de la ramenez nous on a
du matériel pour peut-être la boue mais
c'est la première année que la
ressourcerie propose des ateliers
mobiles dans des quartiers prioritaires
mais elle a commencé cette
sensibilisation dès 2015
l'idée de base de ces ateliers il allait
en complément en fait avec des campagnes
de collecte d'objets qui étaient le plus
souvent abandonnés dans les parties
communes
on constate que c'est important en fait
de venir dans ces lieux là pour parler
du réemploi qu'est ce qu'un déchet est
ce que c'est quelque chose qui est cassé
est ce que c'est quelque chose dont je
n'ai plus l'âge et souvent les habitants
sont très heureux en fait qu'on vienne
leur parler d'eux un peu d'écologie
aussi parce que ça les concerne et
souvent ils ont pas forcément les
réponses aux questions qu'ils se posent
mais on pleines vacances pluvieuses le
quartier semble très calme des habitants
des intéressés non praetor que l'équipe
pour qui la fluence reste imprévisible
c'est pas un échec pour nous
on a parlé avec des passants avec des
jeunes des moins jeunes et voilà ça même
ce même ce qu'on a avec lesquels on n'a
pas le temps de parler il voit et c'est
aussi des petites graines voilà semer
les graines d'une nouvelle façon de
consommer sans tout jeter mais pour
changer les habitudes
le meilleur levier reste l'argent avec
le principe du pollueur payeur
[Musique]
7h30 du matin les éboueurs font la
tournée des ordures ménagères des
poubelles grises ordinaire en apparence
elles sont en fait scanner est identifié
à chaque fois qu'elles sont vides et les
trouvent elles sont munies d'une puce
qui permet d'enregistrer la levée afin
de facturer au nombre de ramassages dans
l'année chaque ramassage est donc
comptabilisé un habitant avec une petite
poubelle paye actuellement un forfait de
60,2 euros pour 26 ramassage par an et
quand ils dépassent ce forfait
ils payent pour chaque levée
supplémentaire d'élever géolocalisés et
transmise à cet ordinateur toutes les
gouttes verte se sont tous les bacs qui
ont été vidés donc si on prend un bac au
hasard avenue des pensées je vois le set
à venus dépenser le bac était vide et à
8h49 ce matin deux balles a lancé il y a
6 ans cette taxe dite incitatives s'est
révélé très efficace
oui la plus grosse surprise c'est
l'effet radical sur la baisse du tonnage
puisqu'on a perdu la première année 25
ans on dit d'un jeu au m1 d'ordures
ménagères
bon on savait que ça pouvait amener ce
type de résultat mais on pensait pas que
ça l'espère moindre conséquence les
habitants trient davantage
retour à angerville pour la collecte des
emballages ses poubelles de tri sélectif
ne sont pas munis d'une puce mais les
éboueurs les fouilles pour vérifier
qu'il n'y a pas d' ordures non
recyclables comme ce bac à pot de fleurs
en plastique
il colle une étiquette qui explique
pourquoi le tri et non conformes mais
pour l'habitant pris en faute
trier est un art complexe l'a donc si on
veut se débarrasser comme des vieilles
poil deçà du coup c'est pas si on doit
on peut les mettre dans celle là où il
faut que sa mère a décrété si seulement
2% des habitants trient mal leurs
déchets dans ce quartier pavillonnaire
le problème est d'une tout autre ampleur
dans les immeubles
on a mis aussi des bacs de collecte qui
va côté dans bien des cas on est obligé
de les enlever
puisque c'était pas respecté
malheureusement il suffit d fois d'une
famille dans un logement collectif pour
souiller l'effort de tout un tas
d'autres
en attendant de trouver une solution le
syndicat qui gère les ordures ménagères
vient d'abaisser le forfait de 26 à 20
ramassage de poubelles par an pour
inciter les contribuables à poursuivre
leurs efforts
elles sont aujourd'hui dans la région
six intercommunalités
cette ressourcerie une quinzaine
d'épicerie en vrac a tenté de réduire
recycler réutiliser
mais le chemin vers le zéro déchet est
encore long
[Musique]